I'm sure by now you guys have heard of
the six women that just went to quote
unquote space for 11 minutes. There's
some very interesting things that I want
to show you guys and discuss. One of
those people were Katie Perry. She is no
stranger to occult themes and ancient
Egyptian symbology. And this time it was
no different. We see in the video when
she went to space, she threw up the
monarch butterfly over one eye. This is
the Illuminati MK Ultra symbolism that
we see these artists do all throughout
their careers. These women are entering
into a rocket ship that looks like this.
Yeah, I don't even have to explain what
it looks like because you know exactly
what it looks like. This is phallic
worship. This all has to do with
fertility rights and it happens in the
springtime. What day did they do this
on? April 14th. This is when these
fertility phallic cults do their
rituals. And these people are obsessed
with numerology and astrology. And I
don't think it's a coincidence that when
you add the numbers four for April and
the numbers 14, you get the number 9.
This was the 11th crew to go up on Blue
Origin 9 and 11. They were in space for
11 minutes. And there were six females,
which six is an occult number, but
upside down is the number 9. So again,
you have 911. I don't think these are
coincidences. Before they actually get
inside the rocket, they all hold hands
and begin to pray. We know Katy Perry
said a long time ago, "I sold my soul to
the devil." Sold my soul to the devil.
Yeah. She used to be a Christian artist,
but she walked away from that. Even in
the interviews after this, you'll hear
her talking about the universe and
meditation. And I have to surrender and
trust that the universe is going to take
care of me. Learned in my life from
meditation to the Hoffman process. So,
who is she praying to? So, we're told
that they were in space for 11 minutes.
Right here you can see on the timeline
that this is an hour and 31 minutes into
the live coverage. This is where they
first enter into space and feel zero
gravity. They are experiencing zerog for
the very first time in their lives. And
here it is literally 1 minute later on
the timeline an hour and 32 minutes in
and the craft is falling down. This is
not space travel. This is what they call
parabolic flight. When you're in an
airplane, you go up so high and the
airplane drops and you feel the feeling
of weightlessness. Parabolic flight is
when an airplane simulates zero gravity.
This is not space travel. And I want you
to notice on the timeline of this live
footage. It's an hour and 45 minutes in.
And watch the door closely. uh out of
out of her her her mouth, but really her
heart when she and is that is that
that door just opened up from the inside
and the lady on the outside peaked in
and said something and the door shut
again. Now 3 minutes later, Jeff Bezos
comes over there to officially pry open
the door. Here goes Jeff Bezos to open
the hatch.
She didn't really close it again. Uh,
they're cheering like they've been
trapped inside this whole time and
couldn't get out until Jeff Bezos come
over there and pried open the door, but
we just saw the door open up. This isn't
even a conspiracy theory. Just use your
eyes. What is going on here? This is an
act. Why would you stage any of this if
this is a legitimate space travel? So,
symbols are a universal language. my
dear friends um threw me a blastoff
party and gave me this feather um which
obviously you know represents the blue
origin logo. Why? Why a feather? This is
already a a pagan ritual. So let's go
back to what's the pagan origins of a
feather. This is the symbol of the
ancient goddess M. She is the goddess of
truth, justice, harmony, and balance as
well as cosmic order. Hint hint, new
world order. That's what they're
ushering in. Another symbol of hers is
the balance, the scales. Now, if you
think this is some kind of stretch, I'm
going to look at their official logo,
and you're going to see that there is a
scales in the logo. If you zoom in on
the bottom left corner, you'll see right
there the scales of the Egyptian goddess
M. This is not a coincidence. Why in the
world would that scales be there for no
reason? This is purposeful. And when you
turn this logo upside down, I'm not even
going to tell you what it looks like.
You tell me. She's not the only one
wearing a symbolic symbol on her
necklace. Look at Gail King's necklace.
She has the literally the symbol of the
sun. They even each rung a bell. And in
the occult, ringing a bell as a ritual
is to clear a space, invoke a deity or
spirit, mark the start of a right, and
create a sacred space. So they were
literally initiating this pagan ritual
right there by ringing the bells. Then
they walk through an archway that says,
"Light the candle," which is part of a
ritual to represent the presence of a
deity and also channel energy. They're
openly telling you that this is a pagan
ritual. Then two of these women get out
and they kiss the earth, which is a
ritualistic act of respect, reverence,
and connection to the earth. All of this
is about mother earth, divine feminine,
and the goddess M. So you got six
witches, I mean women. One of them
openly said she sold her soul to the
devil. Talks about channeling. Has a
song about falling in love with an
extraterrestrial demon. Then they pray,
ring bells, enter into the phallic, fly
up in the air, cover one eye, land on
the earth, kiss the earth, and give
interviews about meditation,
spiritualism, and mother earth and the
divine feminine. Divine feminine right
now. We saw significance in numbers
being 9, 11, and 6. We saw a patch
that's literally a goat head upside
down. We saw the scales and the feather
of m. We heard the divine feminine, the
push for the universe that protects you,
the meditation propaganda, the fakery of
the door not being opened until Jeff
Bezos opens it up. And why? What is this
all for? People are spending millions of
dollars flying up in the air and falling
back down when we're still trying to
find cures for cancer. This is all
spiritualism propaganda pushing you
towards the one world religion. All of
this is for a purpose. And all of this
is setting the stage for Satan's last
final deception. Are you ready? Candid
truth.
[Music]